Okay. Here's the code for the compiler.
Now, remember the way the compiler works is the constructor for each of the patterns
takes some arguments--a string, and x and y pattern, or whatever--
and it's going to return a function that matches the protocol that we've defined for the compiler.
The protocol is that each pattern function will take a set of numbers
where the set of numbers is a list of possible lengths that we're looking for.
Then it will return a set of strings.
What have I done for lit(s)?
I've said we return the function which takes a set of numbers as input,
and if the length of the string is in that set of number--
if the literal string was "hello" and if hello has five letters
and if 5 is one of the numbers we're trying to look for--
then return the set consisting of a single element--the string itself.
Otherwise, return the null set.
Star I can define in terms of other things.
Plus I've defined in terms of a function sequence that we'll get to in a minute.
It's a little bit complicated. It's really the only complicated one here.
We can reduce all the other complications down to calling plus, which calls genseq.
Sequence does that too.
I've introduced epsilon, which is the standard name in language theory for the empty string.
So it's the empty string.
It's the same as just the literal of the empty string,
which matches just itself if we're looking for strings of length 0.
For dot--dot matches any character.
I've decided to just return a question mark to indicate that.
You could return all 256 characters or whatever you want.
Your results would start to get bigger and bigger. You can change that if you want to.
I levt space for you to do some work.
Give me the definitions for oneof(chars).
If we ask for oneof the characters abc, what should that match?
What it should match is if 1 is an element of Ns then it should be abc.
Otherwise, it shouldn't be anything.
Similarly for alt. Give me the code for that.